today i'm going to show you how to build
dashboards in excel with a very
straightforward technique
i use this approach on almost every
single project
that i worked on during my time in
consulting at mckinsey
the dashboards that i created this way
not only were super straight forward to
create
and i will show you in this video how
exactly you can create it
in only 15 minutes or so but they also
regularly impressed
both clients and also other team members
because they usually pretty cool
super helpful super straightforward so
welcome to another coffee break here on
my channel firm learning
help yourself to a coffee my name is
heinrich and on my channel from learning
i want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career i'm a
former mckinsey consultant i spent about
six years with the firm
and for sure excel was one of the tools
i used
most and i'm very excited to teach you
about some of the skills that i found
most useful during my professional life
if you're interested in this type of
content check out my channel because i
already did several other videos
on excel tips and tricks like this and
if you're actually interested to play
around with the dashboard that i created
yourself if you maybe just want to use
it to
code along try it out for yourself train
a bit maybe also see how exactly i did
something and maybe you couldn't follow
a specific part of the video
i'm offering this very dashboard that
i'm creating here with you today for
free as a download if you're interested
in that check out the link in the video
description to download this dashboard
for you and then try it out and play
around with it
and i would like you to introduce you to
the sponsor of this video data camp data
camp is an
online learning platform where you can
improve your data analysis skills and
you know that this is something i talk
about
all the time this is really a crucial
part of your skill set
if you want to succeed in any consulting
role and i trust in many roads in
industry
and for sure in banking as well with
datacam that no previous data skills
needed to get started
you can learn from things as basic as
xl101
to more advanced technical things like
for instance database manipulation and
sql
so for sure if the things that i show
you here in this video
are over your head you really have no
idea what this is all about there are
some also very introductory courses on
excel in data camp which i trust can
help you they have over 300 courses with
interactive learning and you can also
learn on the go with the mobile app that
they have
personally i very much like the
introduction to sql course which already
helped me several times on my own
projects when i needed to interact with
databases
so give it a try and i trust that
working with data camp indeed can fast
track your data analysis skills
and these for sure are so crucial in any
consulting role but also many other
related roads as well
so this now peaked your interest and you
would like to try out data camp then
invest in yourself
use my link to data camp in the video
description and try out the first
chapter of every course for free
so let's start by looking into what we
want to build in the end i don't know
put this here into the reference
sheet this is pretty much what we want
to build and you see here a pretty basic
dashboard of course this now does not
look overly complex
so i did not wanted to make the video
too long but the key thing is that if
you understand how this works
you can pretty easily expand into much
more complex extensive dashboards
then of course it's also not really
difficult to then just add some
additional charges in there as well
and the key idea is that this could for
instance be a retail store
and then there at the store selection
there's a drop down
where you can select different stores
and then all the numbers update
accordingly
i really adjust you to my screen
recording that you cannot see the
overlay of the drop down
but if you then download the file then
you will see just the normal drop down
that appears without
all the stores so this is it again
pretty straightforward
but this type of drop down based
modeling this type of drop down based
dashboards
this is really important and i built
this so frequently in consulting
just extremely helpful but let's get
started and let's try to just
build this here together so i created
here an empty sheet
and now i'm starting to to format it i
always like to create these
little edges at the end i believe it
always looks a little bit cleaner
instead of just starting off from the
beginning
so i'm just looking back at the
reference sheet to see how exactly it's
supposed to be set up
so just to copy the text and so on so
dashboard
for the sage performance so in this
example
uh the different items that you select
in the drop-down or different stores
but of course this could easily be a
company where then look at different
product lines so different geographies
different business units right so all of
these things could be easily built
with such a dashboard and trust me this
would be really helpful really
insightful to many companies
now here i'm just creating the front end
right i always believe it's helpful to
start to create the front end
to start to create the things that are
supposed to come out in the end and this
often helps
at least me later to then fill it and
all the fields that the later should
contain
dynamic content i already highlight them
with a border
in order now for me later than to make
it more clear what is expected
now i copied this border from top to
bottom i
often believe it is easy directly copy
it so that it has exactly the same
height
this always makes it look a little bit
cleaner and now
i am coloring it just to
create this little head area
and now i'm freezing it so that i can
scroll now especially if now the
dashboard would be a little bit bigger a
bit more extensive then it might be
helpful
to really fix this header segment over
there so that you can still scroll down
and still see the header
now again copying the elements revenues
and margins just typing here
the text nothing fancy happening for the
moment
so this is the revenues and margins
section
we have the current trading so the
current ref net revenues and then also
the profit
as well as the margin that is created
okay so next is then that we also want
to expand this a little bit
just that it looks a bit more like the
original example in the reference sheet
now we are bolding this so far so good
and now let's create just a little line
below just to show that this is kind of
a sub-header
the revenues and margins sub-header for
this section of the dashboard
okay this looks good to me and now i am
continuing to build the front end by
again putting borders
around these fields that the later will
be filled
with numbers and this is actually in
this example the dashboard where we have
the data
from january to end of november so let's
assume for instance you would be in
december of 2020 so december of last
year
now we would build a dashboard that goes
from january to november
and then this is now the data that is
captured here is also shown in the last
updated timestamp field
now we have the cumulative data so from
january to november
and then in this dashboard example it
shows the last five months right so july
august september october november
this is of course arbitrary now i can
see that i need to shift
in the column k this little bit around
so this matches the example
and now here i just copy it from above
now i'm
adjusting the column widths right so i'm
making all of these of the same width i
think this is now the width size 15.
so this makes it look a little bit
cleaner now again i'm making
these distances a little bit smaller
copying it over there so that i'm sure
that i'm
getting the exact same distance here
and next i am now further cleaning it up
but let's see what i put next
exactly this can be a little bit bigger
as well let's also put this to
15. this now looks a little bit
better i'd say and now we are continuing
to build the lower section so
performance comparison
here again then the historical
development so this is not the section
where you want to compare the current
performance
to how the performance looked like in
the last years
so here we have again the gross revenue
we have
the profit as well and we also have
the margin
all right so far so good and now here
what we want to have is now for the
years 2015 to 2019 so for the last five
years so now assuming currently we are
in 2020
that then we see the change now here
we're putting the the year information
so that we have this way covered this
way
so what i like to do now is to adjust
these grid lines so that the grid lines
are not appearing anymore
so this i believe always gives a much
cleaner look so can very much recommend
this just for this nice clean look that
we want
and now let's start looking into the
different data inputs so here we have
the stores tab so here you see these
10 stores let's just assume this retail
store has 10 stores around the world you
see a store id store name the city
and the type of stores apparently we
have here flagship and boutique
so only these two types then we go to
the next tab this is the revenue 2020
tab so this is a month to date right so
it contains all the months
until now so this example it has the
data from january to november
so you see per store the different
monthly data
what's important to understand is that
this is data that can easily come out of
any business intelligence system this is
just a flat table with all the data
pretty much any information system that
businesses have can give you such an
output
and this is what you're always looking
for you're looking for these clean
tables that you can then use
and then also later if you can update it
just copy in the new report copy it into
here
and then pretty much the whole dashboard
updates automatically right this is
pretty much the goal
and this is what then will be achieved
by setting it up in such a way in a way
that is also shown here right here you
have the different months again this
ends
at november and then you have the net
revenue and
the cost the cost of goods sold so the
cost and here now in the history tab
we have the years 15 16 17 18 19 again
flat table format this will come out of
every business intelligence bi system
that you have
and then you can use the data for the
dashboard
so far so good so let's build it let's
get practical let's see how exactly
this is done so let's start by creating
the drop down for the store selection so
the drop down for this field
and here again i think it doesn't show
you the overlays but you need to click
on data
and then in the data menu on data
validation
and then the menu that pops up you click
then the list
type and then you can select from kind
of a list of cells
that you should use as an input for the
drop down and of course
these input cells should be the store
names so you know highlight these
store names and then you press okay and
then these are exactly all the names
that then appear in the drop-down again
unfortunately you cannot see it here
but here you can select one of these so
you select you see now that i
clicked in the drop down these different
names
now i will um center it and also color
it
white because i believe it looks a
little bit cleaner this way
and now here this would for instance be
the drop down for i believe this is dla
store but now
to get exactly this done let's first
start by now also putting the store id
because maybe some employees are more
used to working with the store id the
number
instead of just the name so we will do
exactly that we will pull that
based on a lookup function and we will
now start actually using vlookup for
that
and i know that i told you you shouldn't
use vlookup and
in a prior video of mine so check that
out for the whole argument i will use
vlookup
now because i believe this is a function
that will be a bit more
well known to most of you it's pretty
much just a lookup function
um if you again if you want to know what
this is all about check out the video i
made on this i will link it somewhere
above here so that you can have the full
picture
and the idea now is that he pretty much
picks the name so the la as the washing
example before
then you need to select the table array
and then he looks into here now this
example
of the column b he looks for the name
and then looks in this example if you
put the two for the second column to the
right
to then return you the id and indeed now
for
la it returns the store id
number four um and indeed if you look at
it la it had the number four next to it
the primer looks okay where is la
what is next to it then this is the
number that you get and you can see now
if you
toggle between all the different stores
in the drop down
then now suddenly you have the store
number that is changed accordingly
so let's now indeed also fill here the
city because now of course you want that
based on the selection
the city gets shown in the correct way
as well so again we use
the vlookup we take the store name on an
action or you could also use the story
because we have it here as well
you highlight it and now for the city it
is the third column you always start
by the first column of the selection in
the vlookup formula
to then count and then that's the third
and then we can just copy it over and
use the number four
to give us the type as well and new york
was
as you have seen in the table before a
flagship store
indeed so hope this makes sense check it
here
flagship store new york this is what it
is guys
so now we build this here as well we can
again it looks in the first column and
then you count one two
three four so the flagship is now in the
column four so this is why then there's
the number four again just
basis of vlookup and you see now that if
you toggle the store selection
then on the right the inputs will change
as well so let's now continue to fill
these fields and we will start now
with the cumulative value so the value
for
january to november and we will do all
of this with the sum
if formula so again if you want to know
how some if exactly works
check out the video edit on that because
i already covered this extensively i
will link it above here
but pretty much the idea is that with
some if you can
mark a column where you want to sum the
values from
but then you can define conditions so
that these values only get summed up
if certain conditions are met and here
of course
first of all we want to start with the
store right because we only want to sum
the values
that are from the store that is
currently selected so you know we need
to highlight that he only
sums the values that in the column a of
the revenue tab
has the same value as here in the store
selection and if we do that now he gives
us
this crazy number here now of course it
is not formatted properly
so i will just format it in the um
in the accounting format the accounting
format usually is my go to
to do this again i just opened the the
formatting menu here just to format it
with the accounting format
and now with with copying of the format
i pretty much
copy or format copy this formula to
these other cells
and now to get the month value we need
to pretty much just copy it over this
whole some
formula that we just had and we need to
extend it we need to define another
restricting condition
because now we want to restrict it not
only to the store but also to the month
so we want to
only sum the values they had the store
as new york whereas the value that we
put
but also that have as a monthly value
only the month that is selected
and thankfully enough i'm already at the
column with the month names
so i can directly select july i need to
log in
uh the the rows but can
freely then change the columns and this
way if i copy it over
you can see a directly tracked the
columns correctly it fixed the row
and now we have the monthly values
looks good so far so now we continue
here with
the gross profit and as you know profit
is revenue minus
cost revenue minus cost so what we need
to do is we need to take the revenue
which already have above
and then we need to subtract the cost
from it right
so let's start by putting the cost here
so for to do that we
take the formula you see that he is
summing up currently the column e
in the revenue tab the column e but of
course the column e
was the revenues so now we need to
instead of the revenues sum up the cost
of course with the same conditions so if
we go back we see that revenues again
are in column e but now we want to sum
the values in the
column f so again so we copy in the
exact same formula
we just change the column input from e
to f
and this way now it gives us the cost
but again we want the profit
so we need to take the revenues which we
have
already calculated above there and then
we deduct the cost
and then it gives us the profit so the
revenue that we have above
minus the cost this is what will give us
the profit now same thing is true here
for
the monthly figures we copy in the
formula for the revenue we replace the e
with an f because this is what will give
us the cost
and then we take the revenues from above
we subtract these costs
so then get the values and then because
we've set it up correctly with all
uh the fixed formulas etc we can just
copy it over
and for the margin we just take the
percentage and calculate it here of
course this is now to be formatted
as a percentage figure and then we have
pretty much the gross margin that we are
calculating here
so again basic high school math um
i hope you can follow along hope this is
not too complicated
all right i'm just copying the format of
the percentage formatting below to the
margin line this way
and now you can see that if you just
toggle around the stores
all of this gets adjusted accordingly
so next historical development um again
the values from the different years
again we can also do this with some ifs
some with this always super helpful with
these things i just love some of these i
pretty much use it all the time because
it's so versatile you can use it for all
kinds of different things
so often i just also abuse some is
pretty much just as a lookup
so but i pretty much use it for
everything right and what we need to do
here is that we just take some ifs
now indeed we need to pull the yearly
figures for 2015
right for 2015 for this specific store
of course so again we set up the some
ifs formula
and to do this accordingly and now we
need to go into this history
tab and
then we select the gross revenue column
here this is now where we want to sum
the values from
then we set the conditions so here the
year column
and then we again tell him that he only
needs to sum
the values that have a year 2015 in this
example in the year column
and then we fix the lines and then we
can just copy it over
okay so hope this makes
sense but now actually i noticed that i
forgot something because of course i
should not only restrict it by the years
but i also need to restrict it by the
stores because otherwise he's giving me
the sum of all the store figures but i
only want the sum of um
the lines but then he has the specific
store that i selected right which is why
i now introduce the second condition
into the summit formula
namely the condition of the stores
so the next one is the cost here again
revenue was in column e the cost was
in column f so you know the drill we
just go back we copy the formula from
above we replace the e by df
but again now we have only the cost but
we want the profit so we take the
revenue and we deduct
the cost from it so this then gives us
the profit
and again we just calculate the margin
to see what the gross margin was looking
like
and of course what you can see is that
apparently
in the current year january from
november the margin was much smaller 33
so the store is apparently down and now
we just calculate the percentage change
from 2015 to 2019 so for this five year
period
so this is just basic calculation of a
percentage change so the one value over
the other minus one
we change the format to percentage
figures and then this is what you get
again basic high school math hope you
can follow along
um and again what you see here now this
store has a little growth
the others are down the others are down
so you see apparently tough times in
retail at the moment right
so this is what it is okay so what we're
left here is now the trend line and for
this i
i use the sparkline functionality of
of excel so what you can do is it just
directly gives you this little chart
here right so you need to just highlight
the values from which you want to
generate the sparklines
then you click um once you've done this
on insert
then you click on sparklines again you
can see it but just click on sparklines
and then you click on lines and then he
asks you okay where do you want to
let this sparkline diagram to be shown
right so where do you want this to
appear
and then you just click in the field
where this is supposed to appear so this
is now the trend field
and you press ok and then it directly
gives you the the sparkline
so super easy super straightforward but
i will guess this is a little touch
and now you can just copy it down and
then it directly shifts the rows
down to the rows where you want to apply
this to and you see this is correct
right in october there was a spike
and then there was quite a crash in
november this is exactly what you see
here in this diagram as well
looks good to me again let's compare to
the reference sheet
so it looks pretty similar i'd say let's
compare the values for new york
as you see these are the exact same
values that we have on this reference
sheet as well so again looks good and
looks
correct to me let's not toggle down
around a bit here in our version as well
looks are good and again so my point is
now this of course is a
rather basic version so but if you can
build
things like this this will put you ahead
of
95 of people that work in corporate
firms trust me guys this is something
that 95 of people in even bluetooth
companies cannot do
and this of course was a basic example
of of a dashboard so this was pretty
straightforward
pretty basic but now with this you can
easily expand it
with this technique i i built much more
complex dashboards right that i just
cannot show you now just for the sake of
the time
but pretty much dashboards but then you
can also include
information on your employees that work
in the stores maybe more complex data
on the different categories that are
being sold merchandise categories that
are being sold
how this now compares to the previous
year you can then also include little
charts just with the basic
excel chart functions so this is super
versatile and this
can really create very powerful
dashboards
and i've really seen clients very often
be super impressed even
clients working in managerial accounting
and controlling departments by how quick
and how straightforward you can build
these dashboards
and then of course updating them can be
super easiest way to just copy in
the new monthly report once the new
month has finished then maybe you just
need to do little adjustments
on the month columns and as you've seen
because the month is directly linked
into the table
just if you put a new name of in your
month in the overview right in the front
end
then directly it automatically pulls all
the right numbers automatically so this
is really
just a great way to set this up and this
is something i can really recommend you
to do
so i hope this was helpful again if you
want to download the sheet there is a
link in the video description where you
can download for free
this very dashboard that we now created
together here today and if you have any
questions
as always just leave me a comment below
in the comment section
i will answer every single comment that
you write and as you know if you write a
comment it also helps me because lots of
comments look go to the youtube systems
if you took any value out of this video
at all please hit the like button for
the youtube algorithm and also subscribe
to my channel to stay up to date on all
my content if you want to see even more
from me follow me on my instagram my
handle is firm learning
and you can also reach out on linkedin
again link to the linkedin in the video
description and i want to say thank you
again to datacam for sponsoring this
video
if you're interested to try out datacamp
yourself feel free to check out the link
to them i already took several courses
on datacad myself and i can tell you
that the courses are high quality and i
also want to say thank you to all the
members of the channel
thank you so much for your contributions
you're really making a difference for my
work
and if you are interested to become a
member as well hit the join button next
to the subscribe button to learn about
all the perks that you will get if you
decide to become a member so if you
watched until the very end now let me
know in the comments that you did and
thank you for doing that i release
weekly videos every single saturday
so looking forward to next week's video
with you guys
until then good weekend to all of you
this is jaime from for learning
bye